[Music]
there is no part of me
that thinks that was the right way
to
behave
keep my wife's name
i've reached out to
chris and the message that came back is
that
he's not ready to talk
and when he is
he will
reach out will smith is smacked out of
me i will say to you chris
i
apologize
to you
my behavior
was
unacceptable i want to apologize to
chris's mother i saw an interview that
chris's mother did
when will slapped chris he slapped all
of us but he really slapped me
why do you say that
because when you hurt my child you hurt
me i wasn't thinking but how many people
got hurt in that moment will broke his
silence in an emotional 5-minute and
44-second video he posted to youtube
instagram and facebook
the oscar winner answering three
questions he posed to himself including
this moment
after jada rolled her eyes did she tell
you to do something
no
it's like
you know i'm i made a choice
on my own
from my own experiences
why didn't you apologize to chris in
your acceptance speech
i was fogged out by that point it's all
fuzzy
so far no response from chris but a
source tells e.t he's focused on moving
forward in his own way but is obviously
aware that this has become a global
phenomenon at a comedy show this week he
joked quote anyone who says words hurt
has never been punched in the face
we'll also apologize to his fellow oscar
nominees including winter quest love i
can still see
quest love's
eyes it happened on quest love's award
and it's like i'm sorry really isn't
sufficient disappointing people is my
central trauma i'm human and i made a
mistake and i'm trying not to think of
myself as a peace
and if you hang on i promise we'll be
able to be friends again